speaking of which I told you the SBA is
the DMV of small business highly
inefficient they you know there's five
or six people there that try really hard
and rest of them don't give a rip and I
told you when the SBA started making
these PPP loans that you guys were going
to get a mess screwing around with them
so this from Bloomberg the Small
Business Administration's loan
processing platform went down Monday for
as long as four hours crash their
computers temporarily halting the
ability of lenders to process loans for
small business owners seeking relief
from the impact of the coronavirus an
SBA official said later that the system
was up and running and said it's not
accurate that the system crashed around
here and we have something go down for
four hours we call that a crash without
elaborating of course the SBA continues
to process approve and guarantee
billions of dollars in loans per hour
does that not give you chill and
continues to add lenders to the system
the official said the system glitch is
the latest glitch in the rocky launch of
the three hundred and forty nine billion
three hundred forty nine thousand
million payroll protection program which
aims to issue loans meant to help small
businesses as part of the two trillion
dollar oh god I can't breathe stimulus
package President Donald Trump
acknowledged there were minor glitches
master of the understatement in the SBA
program during the daily White House
coronavirus briefing on Monday but added
the loan process is very fast yeah
except for that four-hour delay part
what a load of crap you used car
salesmen
seriously dude unbelievable Oh God they
were swamped they were actually swamped
he said well yeah I think let's see
you're gonna wave it out there you're
gonna call it alone but say it's gonna
be forgiven and you don't think there's
gonna be a rush on the bank maybe you
ought to have your
technology crap in place if you're gonna
launch something like this just maybe
Dave I've spent my career dealing with
outside the bell curve events things
went when it couldn't get any crazier or
worse for somebody in the last week or
two I've I'm just Linda you're living
outside the bill I don't know what to
say anymore yeah we're all outside the
boat this was a wild movie and then it
turned into this script would get
rejected in Hollywood as not plausible
they'd say hey that one sharknado or
something um II thought of this and
actually got this on film you know
that's what would happen if you filmed
it I would have failed the freshmen in
high school for writing this down as
their short story that's not gonna
happen
come on man I mean really get your plot
straightened out here you got it you
gotta make it believable for the reader
or you lose them I don't even know what
to say anymore I this is a strange world
where I find myself speechless well you
can't make this crap up is what I mean
the SBA is down for hours with billions
of dollars an hour going out this is
like this is like shutting down the
water main to LA for four hours and
nobody can get water for four hours in
Los Angeles or New York City that's what
it would be like I mean it can you
imagine ah'd a oh well they were really
swamped oh we had some minor problems a
glitch minor glitches on Monday then you
make a sign-up sheet for billions and
you don't think I just yeah I don't know
man I tell no well those of you that
have not gotten your PPAP loans we have
been clearly recommending that you don't
because there is the word loan in this
process and Dave Ramsey team and has
never recommended you go into debt and
you have to meet the federal guidelines
which are always kind of interesting if
you were trying to read the tax code I
mean meet the federal guidelines in
order to have the loan forgiven it is
not a grant it is alone with forgiveness
provisions that you will have to meet
exact and the government is well known
for having a rush to bill through and
then make up the rigs on the back end
and to suit their new mood on the back
end I worked with too many students at
several universities who decided I'm
gonna be a social worker I'm gonna go
into public defense instead chasing big
money law because my heart is big and
and I'm gonna decade decade they're
gonna forgive it right and then they
didn't it's all going yeah I remember
that story the students in times the
student loans that were not gonna be I
mean they were gonna be forgiven that
weren't I remember the story they
changed up change my mind in year nine
right I mean I don't know change your
mind after you've given up a decade of
your earning power mm-hmm
the name of public services take a
lessor job in public service mm-hmm
later on we found out it was alone yeah
you folks I'm telling you this is this
is what's gonna be known as being bit in
the butt both cheeks some of you are
gonna get there some of you're gonna get
the the Rottweiler clamped down I'm just
telling you it's coming some of you'll
get the forgiveness it'll work out I'm
not saying it's a hundred percent scam
I'm just saying you guys are acting like
this is nothing you would be a fool not
to take the in quotes air quotes
everybody free money and then the SBA
I'm telling you the comfort that the
organization you're dealing with can't
keep their computers running does that
mean anything to you I mean you know
when you see lack of competence lack of
integrity with someone you're doing
business with expect to have a lack of
competence and lack of integrity in the
future I mean why would you expect
something else but we always have we
always have this illusion this fantasy
that this time it's gonna for me just
for me they're gonna you know it's gonna
be the short line at the DMV today just
for me I got 30 minutes okay I'm gonna
get right straight through there just
like that
I know it's backed up out the door but
they're gonna be quick today I just know
they are fantasies so much happier play
sometime